los servicios que nos proveen los satélites,
estos requieren de nuestra atención
ya que dejan una marca imborrable
en el espacio que ocupan.
En todo el mundo, la gente depende de la infraestructura satelital en todo momento
sea para buscar información, entretenerse o comunicarse.
Existe incluso un monitoreo en la agricultura, en el medioambiente
en la conexión y navegación web.
Los satélites tienen gran importancia
en el funcionamiento de los mercados financieros y energéticos.
Sin embargo, estos satélites en los que confiamos
día a día,
tienen una fecha de caducidad.
Pueden quedarse sin combustible,
presentar fallas,
o simplemente llegar al fin de su vida útil.
Si fuera así, estos satélites se convierten en chatarra espacial,
abarrotando el entorno de la órbita.
Imaginen que conducen por la autopista en un hermoso día soleado
haciendo toda clase de mandados.
Con la música a todo volumen,
las ventanillas bajas,
la fresca brisa que agita el cabello.
Suena bien, ¿verdad?
Todo parece estar tranquilo,
hasta que, de repente, su auto se sacude y se detiene
justo en medio de la carretera.
No hay otra opción que dejar el auto
en donde está.
Tal vez si tuvieron suerte
lograron dejarlo fuera del camino, en una cuneta
para que no interfiera con el tránsito.
Hasta hace un par de horas,
el auto era una máquina útil en la que confiaban a diario.
Ahora es una pieza de metal inútil
que ocupa espacio en una red de transporte vital.
Imaginen rutas internacionales abarrotadas de vehículos sin funcionar
que solo ocupan lugar en el tránsito.
Imaginen los restos desparramados por todas partes,
si un accidente realmente ocurriera,
miles de pequeños restos
formarían nuevos obstáculos.
Este es el paradigma de la industria satelital;
por lo general los satélites que ya no funcionan
son abandonados en las órbitas durante varios años,
o simplemente se mueven del camino como una solución temporal.
Y no existen leyes internacionales en el espacio
que nos obliguen a retirar esos restos.
El primer satélite del mundo, el Sputnik I,
fue lanzado en 1957
y en ese mismo año hubo tres intentos de lanzamientos.
Décadas más tarde, cientos de países
han lanzado miles de satélites a órbita,
y la frecuencia de los lanzamientos cada vez es más alta,
en especial si se consideran aspectos como la probabilidad
del lanzamiento de más de 900 satélites en constelaciones.
En la actualidad, lanzamos satélites a diversas órbitas
dependiendo en cual sea su uso.
Uno de los lugares más habituales adonde se envían los satélites
es a la parte baja de la órbita terrestre,
probablemente por sobre la superficie terrestre
a hasta una altitud de unos 2000 km.
Los satélites se ven perjudicados por la atmósfera terrestre,
es por eso que es habitual que sus órbitas decaigan
y eventualmente se desintegren,
probablemente en unas cuantas décadas.
Otro lugar habitual adonde enviamos a los satélites
es a la órbita geoestacionaria,
que yace a una altitud de unos 35 000 km.
Allí permanecen en el mismo lugar sobre la tierra mientras que esta gira,
lo que permite servicios de comunicación, o emisión televisiva.
Los satélites en órbitas lejanas podrían permanecer allí por siglos.
Y luego existe "la órbita cementerio",
las órbitas de desechado o de chatarra abandonada
donde se colocan algunos satélites
al finalizar su vida útil
para que permanezcan alejados de las órbitas en funcionamiento.
De los 7.000 satélites lanzados desde fines de los años 50
solo 1 de cada 7 funcionan actualmente
y, además de los satélites que ya no funcionan,
también permanecen miles y millones
de pequeños y grandes escombros
que también orbitan alrededor de la Tierra.
La chatarra espacial presenta alto riesgo para las misiones espaciales,
pero también para los satélites de los que dependemos.
Hoy, debido a que la chatarra espacial es un asunto apremiante,
se han realizado intentos tanto a nivel nacional como internacional
de desarrollar regulaciones técnicas
para limitar la cantidad de escombro adicional.
Por ejemplo, existen sugerencias
para las naves que recorren la órbita baja
para que no permanezcan allí más de 25 años
pero aún ello es mucho tiempo,
en especial si un satélite ha dejado de funcionar en años.
También existen regulaciones para aquellas naves geoestacionarias
para que se trasladen a una órbita cementerio.
Pero ninguna de estas pautas responde a la legislación internacional
y se supone que cada país debe implementar sus normas.
Estas pautas tampoco son a largo plazo,
no son proactivas
tampoco abarcan a la chatarra que ya está acumulada.
Simplemente se limitan a la futura formación de escombros.
Nadie se responsabiliza por la chatarra espacial.
El monte Everest es una interesante comparación
de un nuevo enfoque de cómo interactuamos con el ambiente
y muchas veces se le acusa
de ser el montículo de basura más grande del mundo.
Luego de la conquista del pico más alto del mundo,
los escaladores dejaron toneladas de basura
que han comenzado a generar preocupación
y en los medios se especula que en Nepal
se tomaran medidas contra los montañistas
mediante regulaciones y sanciones estrictas.
Esto es para incentivar a los escaladores
a recoger sus propios residuos,
es por ello que tal vez se recompense a aquellos que contribuyan,
o se organicen viajes para recolectar residuos de forma voluntaria.
Y aún así varios sentirán
que las asociaciones independientes deberían regular por sí mismas.
No hay una solución simple
e incluso los bienintencionados esfuerzos para conservar
muchas veces dan más problemas.
Pero ello no significa que no se deba hacer todo
para proteger al medioambiente del que dependemos
y, como el Everest, la infraestructura inadecuada y remota
de la órbita espacial hace que el deshecho de basura
represente un gran problema.
Pero no podemos crear montañas de basura
cada vez más grandes,
incluso fuera de este planeta.
La realidad en el espacio
es que si una pieza de un satélite se rompe,
son pocas las probabilidades de repararla
y representa un gran costo.
Pero, ¿qué tal si diseñáramos mejores satélites?
¿Qué tal si todos los satélites,
independientemente del país que los construya,
deban seguir un estándar
para su reciclaje, servicio,
o incluso sacarlos de órbita?
¿Qué tal si existieran regulaciones internacionales
que obliguen a desechar los satélites
en lugar de quitarlos del camino
como una solución temporal?
O quizás se le deba cobrar un depósito
a los fabricantes de satélites para lanzarlos al espacio
y este solo se devolvería
si los satélites fueran desechados correctamente
o si retiraran los restos que producen.
O tal vez que posean la tecnología necesaria
para lograr que salieran de órbita rápidamente.
Hay indicios alentadores.
Por ejemplo, el TechDemoSat-1, que el Reino Unido lanzó en 2014,
fue diseñado para desecharse al finalizar su vida útil
mediante un pequeño mecanismo de anclaje.
Esto funciona porque no ocupa lugar,
pero los satélites o sus órbitas ocupan más lugar
ya que juntos o por separado son de gran tamaño
y requerirán de otros métodos alternativos.
Tal vez se lleguen a crear cosas como láseres de largo alcance
o mecanismos de arraste mediante redes o nudos,
aunque suenen descabellados en el corto plazo.
Y una interesante posibilidad
es la de grúas o mecánicos espaciales.
Imagina que un brazo robótico
en alguna especie de grúa espacial
pueda reparar las piezas de un satélite
haciéndolo útil otra vez.
O si ese mismo brazo robótico
pueda recargar el tanque de combustible de las naves
que dependan de propulsión química
así como lo hacemos aquí, con nuestros automóviles.
La reparación y mantenimiento robotizados
podrían extender la vida útil de cientos de satélites que orbitan la Tierra.
Es obvio que este problema
no se reduce a un problema técnico.
Existen leyes espaciales y políticas muy complejas que debemos conocer.
Hemos usado el espacio de forma poco sustentable.
Explorando, innovando, para cambiar nuestras vidas
es lo que hemos hecho,
y en la exploración espacial
nos movemos más allá de los límites terrestres.
Pero al atravesar esos límites,
debemos tener en cuenta a nuestro medioambiente.
Hay acumulación de satélites en la baja órbita terrestre y en la geoestacionaria
y no podemos seguir lanzando satélites
para reemplazar a aquellos que se rompieron
sin intentar repararlos primero
así como no lo haríamos con un automóvil roto
en el medio de la carretera.
La próxima vez que uses tu teléfono móvil,
revises el clima o usen el GPS,
recuerden a la tecnología satelital que lo hace posible.
Pero también recuerden el impacto
que tienen los satélites en el medio ambiente
y que depende de nosotros reducir el impacto.
La órbita terrestre es asombrosamente hermosa
y nuestra puerta para explorar el espacio.
De nosotros depende mantenerla así.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)